bonjour
ça va oui ça va
moi super moi aussi ça va bien
à moi aussi avoir aussi
d'accord
tu sais j'ai vu un film au cinéma
cinéma
j'ai pas compris
et manic
ah
bah je sais au cinéma
adacore ben oui
tu es allé au cinéma
d'accord ok cinéma d'accord j'ai rigolé
en voyant charlie chaplin
je comprends pas c'est quoi
je comprends pas
il ya longtemps tu ne l'as pas vu non je
sais pas
à temps
ah
si je connais charlie chaplin
bah oui je connais ben oui je connais je
connais d'accord c'est le signe de
charlie de charlie chaplin
adacore bah oui j'adore
moi aussi j'aime bien
moi j'aime bien marilyn monroe
tu connais pas marilyn monroe
je ne connais pas reconnaît pas tant je
te montre
oui marilyn monroe est belle
ah c'est comme ça d'accord
ah ouais je savais pas c'est
marilyn a pas d'accord
oui elle est belle
moi j'adore superman
superman
mois
moi non j'aime pas trop superman je
préfère spider man
spider man je ne connais pas reconnaît
pas mais si spider man
à temps
oui spider man
ouais moi j'aime bien spider man c'est
comme ça
à spiderman
je préfère se verra moi non
je préfère spider man
moi j'aime james bond
non
non je connais pas
je n'ai pas compris
je ne sais pas
james bond 007
d'accord bah oui
bah oui james bond il est beau oui c'est
vrai et beau
moi j'aime aussi louis de funès les
regards
ça veut dire quoi
un chapeau
non je connais pas
louis de funès
d'accord à louis de funès
d'accord ok j'avais pas compris
tu veux venir au cinéma avec moi oui on
y va
au revoir
bonjour
film
cinéma
aussi
connaître
charlie chaplin
superman
marilyn monroe
spider man
james bond
louis de funès
au revoir